on va poursuivre avec André castonguet
les directeur général du réseau
québécois des
osbls d'habitation bonsoir Monsieur
Castonguay
alors on vient de montrer toutes sortes
de chiffres là les chiffres du
regroupement des associations de
locataires il y a aussi l'indice du
logement qui a été publié qui chiffrait
à 21 % l'augmentation des loyers entre
2016 et 2021 est-ce que ça correspond à
ce que vous observez là pour quel type
de ménage c'est plus préoccupant plus
critique en ce moment
je le présentement
dans le fond avec la crise du logement
première des choses la crise du logement
ça fait déjà quand même un certain temps
qu'on ne voyait venir même qu'on met
qu'elle était là le cette année je pense
que ça va être encore ça va être encore
plus difficile pour certaines manèges de
se trouver un logement premièrement puis
après ça mais payer la note du logement
donc oui mais quand vous dites on la
voyait venir ça fait longtemps qu'on en
parle et on en parle toujours plus quand
on approche la date du premier juillet
mais il y a quand même des choses qui
ont bougé dans le dossier de
l'habitation dans les derniers mois des
choses qui ont été promises est-ce que
ça avance monsieur Castonguay
qui était qui a été annoncé en 2021 qui
est qui est le premier appel de prochain
en 2022 il y a pas encore d'unités qui
ont été développés encore dans ce
programme-là donc présentement on est en
déficit déjà on est en retard d'un an
sur cette programmation là on a encore
si on regarde le logement social
communautaire et logements logements
pour les gens avec les revenus les moins
élevés on a encore 6000 unités dans le
premier unité dans le programme
accéléralogique qui ont pas encore été
développés
on se rend compte que même les sommes
qui ont été promis dans le dernier
budget c'est amplement insuffisant pour
pour faire ce développement-là je pense
qu'on est vraiment dans une impasse il
va falloir vraiment réagir rapidement
parce que
toute cette semestre nous a vraiment
rattrapé puis on a la face dans le mur
la ministre du ranso dit souvent que le
problème c'est pas un problème de
financement vous semble pas d'accord
c'est impossible à la base sans
programme gouvernementaux présentement
c'est impossible de faire du logement
qui est réellement abordable selon les
revenus des gens qui vont l'occuper
l'aborderabilité c'est une notion qui
est très large c'est henri-it et
vraiment fonction du revenu du ménage je
suis maintenant j'ai pas capable de se
payer un revenu un logement abordable de
1500$
donc oui il y a un manque flagrant on
considère qu'il y a un manque la grande
financement présentement il va falloir
avoir un virage majeur il va falloir
qu'on s'assoit tout autour d'une table
qu'on en discute parce que le
présentement les décisions viennent d'en
haut sauf que la rose est plus ou moins
consultée donc présentement
c'est une des solutions sinon la
solution au problème de pénurie de
logement abordable est-ce que vous êtes
convaincu de pouvoir faire mieux que le
privé et comment
bien évidemment parce que dans le fond
si on parle de l'organisme il y a pas de
notion de profit il y a une notion de
faire quelques surplus pour pouvoir
vraiment entretenir l'immobil l'immobil
l'immobilier par la suite ça prend quand
même des sommes pour pouvoir garder les
immeubles la bon état mais la notion de
profil on l'a pas au niveau du logement
communautaire donc quelque part c'est
plus c'est plus facile évidemment
contrôler justement c'est ces
augmentations de loyer là puis
évidemment sont aussi développés avec
ces programmes-là sont aussi développés
avec les programmes du gouvernement donc
c'est c'est d'autant plus aidant
justement d'être capable d'offrir du
logement réellement abordable ceux qui
en ont besoin le privé
à sa place dans l'application bien
entendu mais c'est on parle pas de la
même offre de logement qu'on parle pas
de la même philosophie justement autour
de l'offre de ce de ces logements-là on
parle beaucoup de construire d'avoir de
nouveaux d'avoir un plus grand parc de
logements abordable le monsieur Gaston
gay mais on a vu on en a parlé beaucoup
dans les derniers mois conversion
d'appartements en condos certains codes
des visions aussi est-ce que dans le
marché actuel qui est extrêmement tendu
avec des chantiers qui se concrétisent
pas est-ce qu'on devrait aussi se
consacrer davantage à la conservation la
préservation du parc de logement
abordable qui existe déjà
qu'on est en demande depuis quand même
quelques années au niveau que ce soit
dans les programmes fédéraux donc qui
ont commencé en 2017 où que ce soit
aussi avec les schq on pense qu'il va
aussi devrait avoir une ouverture
là-dessus on a déjà des grosses au PNL
d'application des gros organismes
justement qui se spécialise justement
dans lesquisition de de nombreuses
unités de logement pour pouvoir les
préserver dans le pack abordable mais je
pense qu'on peut faire mieux encore dans
le fond je pense qu'il faut vraiment
augmenter le pourcentage du logement qui
est vraiment accessible aux gens qui ont
des moins grands retenus être
présentement par rapport au parc locatif
donc on sent vraiment avec cette crise
là cette année qui est encore pire que
les dernières qu'on a connu dans les
dernières années il faut commencer ce
pourcentage d'eau puis ça va presser et
quand le Premier ministre comme il le
laissait entendre hier dit que en fait
des prix qui augmentent dans le secteur
de l'immobilier en fin de compte c'est
une bonne chose parce que c'est synonyme
de gain pour l'économie qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez
je pense que c'est vraiment une vision
erronée bien mal connaître ce qui se
passe sur le terrain avec justement des
manèges parce qu'au-delà des chiffres
c'est des individus qu'on a c'est des
familles qui déménage
à arriver c'est du monde sur tantrisme
en plus des inflations qui étaient
grandissante du monde aussi qui ont des
cartes de crédits qui ont des qui ont
des taux d'intérêts qui ont augmenté je
pense que c'est bien mal connaitre la
base de la société dans le fond les
individus qui ont pas vraiment beaucoup
d'argent qui ont pas les moyens de se
payer ce genre de loyer là présentement
on a vu les chiffres les augmentations
sur farmingus il y a aucun revenu de
personnes qui augmentent le palais
manifeste
extrêmement difficile en ce moment
monsieur Gaston gay merci beaucoup
d'avoir été là ce soir
ça me fait bien plaisir merci Madame
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]